Hi, everybody. It's This American Life. So one of our producers read this book a few months ago, and she was like, this story is really unusual. And, also, it happened to be written in a way that is perfect for radio. Could we maybe just condense it down and run it on the show?
大家好，这里是《美国生活》。几个月前，我们的一位制作人读了这本书，她觉得这个故事非常不同寻常。而且，它恰好是用一种非常适合广播的风格写成的。我们或许可以把它压缩一下，然后在节目中播出。
And so a few of us read the book, including me. And we agreed. This is a story you really don't hear. Basically, the story-- there's this couple. He gets Alzheimer's. And, of course, so many of us know people with Alzheimer's. I feel like it's like watching somebody who you love-- I don't know-- just drift slowly off into space. The things that make them them get taken away, one after another.
于是我们几个人读了这本书，包括我在内。我们一致认为，这是一个你平时听不到的故事。故事的基本情况是——有一对夫妻。丈夫患上了阿尔茨海默病。当然，我们很多人都认识患有阿尔茨海默病的人。我觉得这就好像看着你爱的人——我不知道该怎么形容——只是在慢慢地飘向太空。那些让他们成为他们自己的特质，正一点一点地被剥夺。
And in this couple, the man, while he still had his wits about him, wanted some kind of assisted suicide before it got too late. And so his wife looks around and finds this place in Switzerland to go to. And what makes the book so special is that just-- I don't know-- the dailyness and realness of the way that his wife tells what that was like to go through.
在这对夫妻中，丈夫在意识还清醒时，希望能在病情变得太严重之前选择安乐死。于是他的妻子四处打听，找到了瑞士的这家机构。这本书之所以特别，是因为——我不知道——是因为他妻子在讲述这段经历时，那种极其日常、极其真实的感受。
And they're this interesting couple that you get to know. Very specific people going through this thing that-- honestly, for everybody I have known with dementia or Alzheimer's, I have never met anybody who made this particular choice. And you get to hear how that plays out. And it's very life-sized. You see this couple after they realize he has Alzheimer's. But, also, you see them before, when he's just kind of acting oddly, and it's a little annoying, but she doesn't know why just yet.
他们是一对有趣的夫妻，你慢慢会了解他们。在这段经历中，这些非常具体的人所面临的处境——老实说，在我认识的所有患有痴呆症或阿尔茨海默病的人中，我从未见过谁做出过这样的选择。你可以听到这一切是如何展开的。而且它非常贴近生活。你看到这对夫妻在意识到他患上阿尔茨海默病之后的生活。同时，你也能看到他们之前的样子，那时他只是表现得有些古怪，虽然有点烦人，但她还不知道原因。
And so what we're going to do today in the first part of today's show is that story. And then after the break, it gets lighter. We have another wife and mother. This one, a professional comedian trying to do the best for her family. From WBEZ Chicago, I'm Ira Glass. And let's just get to it.
所以，我们今天节目第一部分要讲的就是这个故事。休息之后，气氛会轻松一些。我们还有另一位妻子和母亲的故事。她是一位职业喜剧演员，正在努力为家人付出最好的一切。来自芝加哥WBEZ，我是艾拉·格拉斯。让我们直接开始吧。
So you may know this book that we're excerpting. It got some attention. It's by Amy Bloom, who has written novels and short stories over the years. So this story is true. And it's her own story. It's called In Love-- the book.
大家可能听说过我们要摘录的这本书。它引起了一些关注。作者是艾米·布鲁姆，她多年来一直从事小说和短篇故事的创作。这个故事是真实的，也是她自己的故事。书名叫《In Love》。
And-- I don't know-- just to say this before we start-- this story is about somebody who's making the very difficult decision to end their life because of a progressive terminal disease which, of course, is very different from somebody thinking about suicide as part of a mental health crisis. But if you are having thoughts of suicide, take all that into account before listening any further. OK.
而且——我不知道——在开始之前我想说，这个故事讲述的是某人因为无法治愈的进行性疾病而做出了极度艰难的决定，选择结束自己的生命。这当然与那些因心理健康危机而产生自杀念头的人有着本质的区别。但如果你正有自杀的念头，请在继续收听之前考虑到这一点。好的。
We are at Act One, Exit Strategy. Here's Amy Bloom.
我们现在进入第一幕：退出策略。请听艾米·布鲁姆的讲述。
Sunday, January 26, 2020, JFK International Airport. This trip to Zurich is a new, not quite normal version of something Brian and I love-- traveling. As we usually do, we take a car service to the airport so we can be fancy and also avoid the park-and-schlep. And even before Brian had Alzheimer's, our combined lack of direction adds 20 minutes to all transportation transitions.
2020年1月26日，星期日，肯尼迪国际机场。这次去苏黎世的旅行，是我们热爱的旅行的一种新版本，虽然不太寻常。像往常一样，我们叫了专车去机场，这样既显得体面，又能避免自己开车和搬运行李。甚至在布莱恩患上阿尔茨海默病之前，我们两个人的方向感缺失就会让所有的交通转换过程多花20分钟。
We have a restaurant meal before our 6:00 PM departure. I buy a stick of lipstick and a small tube of hand cream. Brian buys some candy. We share gum. We share a bottle of water. We are smiling from the moment we board. As soon as we get our beverages-- in glasses-- we toast my sister and brother-in-law who are paying for our business class trip to Zurich.
我们在下午6点出发前吃了一顿餐厅餐。我买了一支口红和一小管护手霜。布莱恩买了一些糖果。我们分享口香糖。我们共用一瓶水。从登机的那一刻起，我们就一直微笑着。当我们拿到饮料——用玻璃杯装的——我们向我的姐姐和姐夫敬酒，感谢他们支付了我们去苏黎世的商务舱费用。
Dignitas's office is in Zurich, and that's where we're headed. Dignitas is a Swiss non-profit organization offering accompanied suicide. And it is one of the very few places in the world to go for painless, peaceful, and legal suicide.
尊严机构（Dignitas）的办公室就在苏黎世，那也是我们的目的地。尊严机构是一家瑞士非营利组织，提供陪同自杀服务。它是世界上极少数可以进行无痛、和平且合法自杀的地方之一。
In our Swissair pods, Brian and I toast each other. And we say, "Here's to you," a little hesitantly, instead of what we usually say, Cent'anni-- "May we have 100 years," a very Italian toast. There is no cent'anni for us. We won't make it to our 13th wedding anniversary.
在瑞士航空的舱位里，布莱恩和我互相敬酒。我们有些犹豫地说：“为你干杯”，而不是我们平时常说的“Cent'anni”——“愿我们长命百岁”，这是一种非常意大利式的祝福。我们没有“长命百岁”了。我们没能走到结婚13周年纪念日。
I've insisted that we don't bring proper suitcases because I will not lug home a large suitcase full of clothes he will never wear and medicines he will never take. I won't dump his clothes at the Swiss version of Goodwill and leave his meds for the cleaning staff. Basically, I just won't deal with it-- with after.
我坚持不带正经的行李箱，因为我不想拖着一大箱他永远不会穿的衣服和他永远不会服用的药回家。我不想把他的衣服扔在瑞士版的慈善商店，也不想把他的药留给清洁人员。基本上，我就是不想处理这些——不想处理“身后事”。
After Brian has died, and I have to leave him, my goal is to get myself on a plane with my friend who has offered to accompany me home. Then my daughter, Sarah, will meet me at the airport. And Sarah and I will be met by my daughter Caitlin. And the two of them will say goodnight to me. And my fantasy is that I will fall into my bed and not get up for two weeks. This is absolutely not what happens.
布莱恩去世后，我必须离开他，我的目标是和我那位主动提出陪我回家的朋友一起登上飞机。然后我的女儿莎拉会在机场接我。莎拉和我会被我的女儿凯特琳接到。她们两个会跟我说晚安。我的幻想是我会倒在床上，两周都不起来。但现实绝对不是这样。
March 2019, Stony Creek, Connecticut. Brian's memory loss began in 2016, and it was small and then bigger and then startling-- names disappearing, repetition, information turned upside down, appointments and medications scrambled. Suddenly, it seemed, we argued endlessly about everything.
2019年3月，康涅狄格州石溪。布莱恩的记忆力减退始于2016年，起初很轻微，后来变得严重，再后来令人吃惊——名字消失，重复说话，信息颠倒，约会和药物混乱。突然间，我们似乎对一切都无休止地争吵。
A gregarious man, he didn't want to see friends except to fish. He now talked only about the past, his childhood, and football. I could not steer him to any other subjects. In the evenings, I said-- because I didn't know any better-- that maybe we could talk about our life now as it's going on-- him and me and his retirement and the kids and the grandchildren and our friends. And he said, sure. But we didn't. And the evenings were hours of television.
他原本是个健谈的人，后来除了钓鱼，什么朋友都不想见。他现在只谈论过去、童年和橄榄球。我无法引导他谈论其他话题。晚上，我说——因为我不知道更好的办法——或许我们可以谈谈我们现在的生活，谈谈他和我的现状，他的退休生活，孩子们，孙辈们，还有我们的朋友。他会说，当然可以。但我们并没有谈。夜晚变成了一小时又一小时的电视节目。
One spring morning, I'd been weeping because Brian seemed so distant. And in that moment, weeping the harder because, although I could see that he was concerned and truly sorry he had upset me, I could also see that he didn't really know why I was upset and reminding him of our long, pointless fight the day before wasn't helping.
一个春天的早晨，我一直在哭泣，因为布莱恩看起来太疏远了。那一刻，我哭得更厉害，因为虽然我能看出他很关心我，也真的很抱歉惹我难过，但我也能看出他并不真正明白我为什么难过，提醒他昨天那场漫长而毫无意义的争吵也无济于事。
We still had the occasional Sunday morning conversations that we'd always had and cherished. Somebody hurt somebody's feelings, and somebody is owed an apology, which will be forthcoming sooner from me, later from him, but delivered by dinnertime.
我们偶尔还会像以前一样，进行我们一直珍视的周日清晨谈话。某人伤害了某人的感情，某人欠了一个道歉，通常我会先道歉，他随后跟上，但总会在晚饭前和解。
Brian was not immune to the lure of the "I didn't say it" or "If I said it, I didn't mean it" approach. But one of the things I loved was his willingness to own up. There'd be a burst of anger. The black cloud would pass. And my husband would dig a little deeper and usually come up with a genuine apology. My favorite-- I'm sorry I was such a knucklehead.
布莱恩并非不会使用“我没说过”或“如果我说了，我不是那个意思”这种借口。但我爱他的特质之一是他愿意认错。偶尔会爆发一阵愤怒，乌云散去后，我的丈夫会深挖内心，通常会给出一个真诚的道歉。我最喜欢的一句是：我很抱歉，我真是个笨蛋。
The cloud didn't pass now. The apology was thin or weary or cold. I could feel him through a glass, and I was banging on it, screaming at him, why is there a glass between us? Where did it come from? Take it down. And Brian looked at me with puzzled, irritated concern and said, in effect, what glass? And please, please stop complaining about this thing that isn't even there.
现在的乌云不再散去了。道歉变得苍白、疲惫或冰冷。我能隔着玻璃感觉到他，我在拼命拍打它，对他尖叫，为什么我们之间有一层玻璃？它是从哪儿来的？把它拿掉。布莱恩用困惑、恼火的眼神看着我，说，实际上，什么玻璃？请，请停止抱怨这件根本不存在的事情吧。
Monday, January 27, 2020, Zurich. We land in Zurich, and the hotel's car service takes us to the pretty hotel in the cobblestoned Old Town section. The city's warmer than we expect, and it's drizzling.
2020年1月27日，星期一，苏黎世。我们在苏黎世降落，酒店的专车把我们带到了老城区鹅卵石街道上的一家漂亮的酒店。城市比我们预想的要暖和，而且正下着毛毛雨。
I feel shifty and out of place at the hotel's front desk. Brian wanders around in and out of the lobby. And when I see him walk through a pair of swinging doors at the end of the hall while I am searching for our passports, my stomach hurts, as it does every time he leaves my sight.
在酒店前台，我感到局促不安，格格不入。布莱恩在大堂里转来转去。当我正忙着找护照时，看到他穿过大厅尽头的一对旋转门，我的胃部一阵紧缩，就像每次他离开我视线时那样。
When he comes back a few minutes later, I've pulled myself together. Every time the concierge asks me a question, I fumble like a suspect. Why are we here? Would we like a map of all the stores on Bahnhof-strasse-- Gucci, Hublot, Cartier? May they show me the bar in the library?
几分钟后他回来时，我调整好了状态。每当礼宾人员问我问题，我就像个嫌疑人一样笨手笨脚。我们为什么来这儿？需要一张班霍夫大街所有商店的地图吗——古驰、宇舶、卡地亚？要带我去看图书馆里的酒吧吗？
I want to say to Brian that it reminds me a little of a hotel we loved in Amsterdam, but I am afraid that he won't remember the trip, the hotel. I'm afraid that he won't, but he will pretend that he does. And I won't know if he does or doesn't, which is awful. Or I will know he doesn't, which is also awful. And I don't say anything, which is usually the choice I make now. We are both exhausted by the time we get to our room.
我想对布莱恩说，这让我想起我们在阿姆斯特丹住过的一家酒店，但我害怕他不记得那次旅行，不记得那家酒店。我害怕他不记得，但他会假装他记得。而我将无法知道他到底记不记得，这太可怕了。或者我知道他不记得，这也同样可怕。于是我什么也没说，这通常是我现在的选择。当我们到达房间时，我们俩都筋疲力尽了。
Spring 2019, Stony Creek. Our normal life had begun to require a level of effort that I'd last had to make when I had had an unhappy marriage, a full-time job, a teenager, a toddler, and a baby-- with none of the joy. Having barely looked at another man or woman for 14 years, I was now imagining myself having drinks on a rooftop lounge with pleasant but unlikely, even unpromising, companions.
2019年春天，石溪。我们正常的生活开始需要一种我上一次经历的努力程度——那时我有一段不幸的婚姻、一份全职工作、一个青少年、一个幼儿和一个婴儿——而且没有任何快乐。已经14年没怎么看过其他男人或女人的我，现在竟幻想自己在屋顶休息室里和一些愉悦但不太可能，甚至毫无前景的伴侣喝酒。
Brian and I were always stickily close. We liked to grocery shop together. Now I exhaled when he went for a long walk and ruminated late at night that maybe I could get him a small apartment in New Haven with some kind of helper if needed. How I could have contemplated helper and manage not to wonder why I was thinking that my 65-year-old husband who read Faulkner and worked out three times a week would need a helper, I couldn't-- absolutely could not say.
布莱恩和我也曾总是黏在一起。我们喜欢一起去超市。现在，当他出去散步时，我会松一口气，并在深夜沉思，也许我可以给他在纽黑文租个小公寓，如果有需要的话再请个帮手。我怎么会考虑请帮手，却没想过为什么我在考虑：为什么我那个65岁、读福克纳、每周锻炼三次的丈夫需要帮手呢？我绝对说不出原因。
I didn't tell anyone in the world that I had these thoughts. I did tell close friends that he was driving me crazy with his male, mid-60s, early retirement loose ends. And it will pass, I said to myself, and look-- he's making stained glass. I found the teacher, made the appointment for the lesson, and located the studio. And he's going to his book club. I scanned the planning emails when he felt overwhelmed, and I ran to the library for the book.
我没告诉世界上任何人我有这些想法。我确实告诉过亲密的朋友，他因60多岁男性的退休初期综合征而快把我逼疯了。这会过去的，我对自己说，你看——他正在做彩色玻璃。我找到了老师，预约了课程，还找到了工作室。他要去参加读书俱乐部。当他感到不知所措时，我扫描了规划邮件，并冲到图书馆去拿书。
And he's pursuing the occasional zoning fights in our little town and studying the town's bylaws with great enthusiasm, so, really, what's wrong? I couldn't say. But I knew that this man was not the man I'd married. And the change had happened not over 50 years, which would have been very sad but not puzzling, but just over the last three years.
他还在我们这个小镇追求偶尔的规划纠纷，并带着极大的热情研究城镇章程，所以，真的，有什么问题吗？我说不上来。但我知道这个男人不是我结婚时的那个男人。这种改变不是在50年里发生的——那样虽然会很悲伤，但不会令人困惑——而仅仅是在过去三年里发生的。
End of life. It's amazing to me that people said to me, well, why go to Switzerland? I mean, why not Oregon or Colorado or Hawaii or Vermont? There are right-to-die laws in those states. That some people said this to me right before and right after my husband died was more than amazing.
生命终结。令我惊讶的是，人们对我说，嗯，为什么要选瑞士？我是说，为什么不是俄勒冈州、科罗拉多州、夏威夷或佛蒙特州？那些州有死亡权利法。在我的丈夫去世前后，有些人对我这么说，这比惊讶更令我感到震惊。
The right-to-die, physician-assisted dying, laws in California, Colorado, Oregon, Vermont, Montana, New Mexico, District of Columbia, and New Jersey, Maine, Hawaii, and Washington require that you be or become a resident of that state-- sometimes quick and easy, not always-- in order to pursue your physician-assisted suicide and also, consistently, that you are mentally competent, medically assessed as having only six months to live, and can express your wish to die-- usually three times, twice orally and once in writing-- to two local physicians.
加州、科罗拉多州、俄勒冈州、佛蒙特州、蒙大拿州、新墨西哥州、哥伦比亚特区、新泽西州、缅因州、夏威夷和华盛顿州的“死亡权”或“医生协助死亡”法律，要求你必须是该州的居民（有时很容易，并不总是），才能申请医生协助自杀。而且，始终要求你必须精神健全，经医学评估只有六个月的生命，并且能表达你的死亡愿望——通常是三次，两次口头，一次书面——并经两位当地医生确认。
Practically speaking, you have to be damn close to death's door to get a doctor to swear that you'll be dead in six months. You have two physician interviews, some days apart, in which you assert that you are not psychotic or suicidal or depressed and hope the doctors agree with you. You have to be able to swallow whatever the doctor prescribes without any assistance.
实际上，你必须离死亡之门非常近，才能让医生发誓你在六个月内就会去世。你需要进行两次医生面谈，间隔几天，在面谈中你要断言自己没有精神病、没有自杀倾向或抑郁症，并希望医生同意你的观点。你必须能够无需任何协助地吞下医生开的任何药物。
Choosing to die and being able to act independently while terminally ill is a deliberately narrow opening. Many people can't get through it. They can't swallow well enough. They can't talk well enough. They can't hold the glass or mix the drink on their own, and helping someone hold the glass is a crime in much of America. People who do wish to end their lives and shorten their period of great suffering and loss-- those people are out of luck in the United States of America.
选择死亡并在绝症期间能够独立行事是一个被刻意缩窄的入口。许多人无法通过。他们吞咽功能不够好。他们口齿不够清楚。他们无法独自拿起玻璃杯或调制饮料，而在美国大部分地区，帮助他人拿起玻璃杯是犯罪。那些希望结束生命、缩短巨大痛苦和损失时期的人们——在美国，这些人只能自认倒霉。
September 2005, Durham, Connecticut. How we met. Brian and I fell in love the way some middle-aged people in unhappy partnerships and in small towns do. Liberal Democrats in a Republican town, ethnic types in a town full of Northern Europeans, opinionated loudmouths, and people who were willing to man the Durham Democrats hot dog stand-- hot dogs and cider-- every September at the fair.
2005年9月，康涅狄格州达勒姆。我们是怎么认识的。布莱恩和我坠入爱河的方式，就像一些在不幸的伴侣关系中、生活在小城镇的中年人一样。在共和党控制的城镇里的自由派民主党人，在全是北欧人的城镇里的少数族裔，固执己见的直言不讳者，以及那些愿意在每年九月的集会上为达勒姆民主党热狗摊——热狗和苹果酒——工作的人。
I overlooked his bad haircut and aviator glasses. I'm sure he had to overlook my lack of interest in sports and my impatience. Brian could talk about a plastic gazebo or additional parking at the library for hours. We had been walking together since our partners were not walkers and talking together in public at our local Democrats breakfast club, and then, suddenly, talking in private.
我忽略了他糟糕的发型和飞行员墨镜。我相信他也得忽略我对体育的没兴趣和我的没耐心。布莱恩可以谈论一个塑料凉亭或者图书馆的额外停车位谈上几个小时。自从我们的伴侣都不爱散步后，我们就开始一起散步，在当地民主党早餐俱乐部公开交谈，然后，突然间，开始私下交谈。
He said, "I was a three-sport captain in high school," and I laughed. He said, "It would have been four sports, but you can't do lacrosse and baseball." "Is that right?" I said. And he took my hand. He said, "What's your family like?" I said, "Jews from New York. You?" He said, "Well, we're a football family. We have three Heisman trophies in my family." I said, "What's a Heisman?" And he kissed me. I kissed him back. And sensibly, we avoided each other for the next year.
他说：“我在高中是三项运动的队长。”我笑了。他说：“本来应该是四项，但你不能同时参加长曲棍球和棒球。”“是吗？”我说。他牵起我的手。他说：“你的家庭是什么样的？”我说：“纽约的犹太人。你呢？”他说：“嗯，我们是一个橄榄球家庭。我家有三个海斯曼奖杯。”我说：“什么是海斯曼？”他亲了我一下。我回吻了他。然后我们很理智地在接下来的一年里避开了对方。
After a year and some martinis in New Haven at the end of the day, he asked me to take a walk with him. He said, "I'm not stupid. I know how this will end. You'll tell me we should not do this to the people we love, or I'll tell you. And we will go back to our lives where we should be, and I will never get over this. Or we blow up our lives and be together.
一年后，在纽黑文喝了几杯马提尼酒结束一天时，他邀请我陪他散步。他说：“我不傻。我知道这会如何收场。你会告诉我我们不应该这样对待我们所爱的人，或者我会告诉你。然后我们会回到各自的生活中，回到我们该待的地方，我永远也无法摆脱这个。或者，我们炸掉我们的生活，在一起。”
"I just want to say this," he said, before we walked back to our cars. "I know who you could be with-- someone rich, someone fancy, some guy your sister finds for you-- but I know who you should be with. You should be with a guy who doesn't mind that you're smarter than he is, who doesn't mind that most of the time you'll be the main event. You need to be with a guy who supports how hard you work and who will bring you a cup of coffee late at night. I don't know if I can be that guy," he said, tears in his eyes, "but I'd like a shot." We married.
“我只想说，”在走回车前，他说，“我知道你可以和谁在一起——某个富有的人，某个时髦的人，某个你姐姐为你找到的男人——但我知道你应该和谁在一起。你应该和一个不介意你比他聪明、不介意大部分时间你是主角的男人在一起。你需要和一个支持你努力工作，并且会在深夜为你端上一杯咖啡的男人在一起。我不知道我能不能成为那个人，”他眼中含着泪水说，“但我想要一个机会。”我们结婚了。
Thursday, August 15, 2019, New Haven, Connecticut. We have an appointment with the neurologist. We get there in plenty of time. The secretary/receptionist nods at us from behind the glass. There are around six million people with Alzheimer's in the United States and many, many more with MCI-- Mild Cognitive Impairment-- often one of the first stages of Alzheimer's but not for everybody.
2019年8月15日，星期四，康涅狄格州纽黑文。我们预约了神经科医生。我们很早就到了。秘书/接待员从玻璃后对我们点头示意。美国约有六百万人患有阿尔茨海默病，还有更多的人患有MCI——轻度认知障碍——这通常是阿尔茨海默病的早期阶段之一，但并非对每个人都是如此。
And although re-evaluation every six months is recommended to people with MCI, no website can tell you why frequent re-evaluation is recommended as there is no successful treatment for MCI, or for slowing the progression of MCI to Alzheimer's, or, really, for Alzheimer's itself. Almost 2/3 of these six million people are women. Almost 2/3 of the caregivers for those Alzheimer's patients are also women. There are lots of theories about why more women than men get dementia but only theories.
虽然建议MCI患者每六个月进行一次复查，但没有网站能告诉你为什么要建议频繁复查，因为MCI没有成功的治疗方法，也没有减缓MCI向阿尔茨海默病发展的有效方法，其实，阿尔茨海默病本身也没有。这六百万人中近三分之二是女性。这些阿尔茨海默病患者的照顾者中近三分之二也是女性。关于为什么女性患痴呆症的人数比男性多，有很多理论，但都只是理论。
I don't have the scientific training to assess these theories. There are no comparable theories about why women make up 2/3 of the unpaid dementia caregivers because no theories are needed. Who doesn't know? Sisters, daughters, wives-- of course they're going to take care of someone with dementia.
我没有评估这些理论的科学训练。关于为什么女性占痴呆症无偿照护者三分之二的比例，没有类似的理论，因为不需要理论。谁不知道呢？姐妹、女儿、妻子——当然，她们会照顾患有痴呆症的人。
Thursday, July 18, 2019, Stony Creek. MRI day. The appointment for Brian's MRI is at 8:45, and it's only 15 minutes away. We both wake up at 6:30. Brian lies in bed for a while grumbling at his phone. He takes his morning meds and tells me he's contemplating a shower.
2019年7月18日，星期四，石溪。核磁共振检查日。布莱恩核磁共振的预约时间是8:45，离家只有15分钟路程。我们6:30就都醒了。布莱恩在床上躺了一会儿，对着手机嘟囔。他服用了晨间药物，并告诉我他在考虑洗个澡。
I encourage the shower because he has a bad case of psoriasis on his scalp, and the only thing that keeps it from trailing into his eyebrows and erupting around his nose is the medicated shampoo he uses every day. We have been talking about the psoriasis shampoo used daily for about a year and a half. Looking back, it seems like a lot of fraught conversation to have about continuing to do something he's done almost every day for the 14 years we've been together.
我鼓励他洗澡，因为他的头皮有严重的银屑病，唯一能防止它蔓延到眉毛并在鼻子周围爆发的方法，就是他每天使用的药用洗发水。关于这个每天使用的银屑病洗发水，我们已经谈论了一年半了。回想起来，对于继续做他在一起14年来几乎每天都在做的事情，竟然有这么多充满焦虑的对话，这真是太多了。
He's a good-looking man. My husband always smelled great and looked good and was vain about his good looks, his wolfish smile, and his dark, thick hair. I didn't mind the vanity which was not excessive and mostly shared only with me. About once a year, he grabbed his stomach and said, if it was free, I'd get a tummy tuck.
他是个英俊的男人。我的丈夫总是闻起来很香，看起来很棒，并且对自己的容貌、狼一样的笑容和浓密的黑发很自恋。我不介意这种虚荣，它并不过度，而且主要是与我分享。大约一年一次，他会抓住自己的肚子说，如果免费的话，我肯定去做个腹部整形。
After he had his cataracts removed, he dragged me into the bathroom to look with him into the mirror. These bags, he said, you never told me. Six weeks later, he was getting an eye lift. When we'd go out to dinner and look out on a sea of men his age, even if we had been in a furious argument, he'd grin, tap me on the hand, and say, how do you like me now? And I'd always laugh.
在他切除白内障后，他拉着我进浴室，对着镜子看。他说，这些眼袋，你从来没告诉过我。六周后，他去做了眼部提升。当我们出去吃饭，看着一片与他同龄的男人们时，即使我们刚刚发生过激烈的争吵，他也会咧嘴一笑，拍拍我的手说，现在你觉得我怎么样？我总是会笑。
I didn't understand why I was now having to say, wash your hair, honey, or, honey, take a shower. Now I understand. And now that I understand, I wish that it was middle-aged man laziness or retirement blues or a man's response to being told what to do. It's not. I've been reading, and it's mild cognitive impairment, which as far as I can tell-- our informative post-MRI meeting with the neurologist will be next week-- a wildly euphemistic name for the early stages of dementia.
我不明白为什么我当时不得不说，亲爱的，去洗洗头发，或者，亲爱的，去洗个澡。现在我明白了。现在我明白了，我希望那是中年男人的懒惰，或者是退休忧郁症，或者是对被告知该做什么的一种抵触。事实并非如此。我一直在阅读，这是轻度认知障碍，据我所知——我们下周将与神经科医生进行信息丰富的核磁共振结果会面——这是痴呆症早期阶段的一个极其委婉的称呼。
The Clock-Drawing Test and the Mini-Mental Status Exam. In our second appointment, the neurologist gets down to it. Brian probably-- in a tone that says definitely-- has a dementing disease. It's probably Alzheimer's-- very, very likely.
画钟测试和简易精神状态检查。在我们的第二次预约中，神经科医生直奔主题。布莱恩很可能——语气中带着确定的意味——患有一种导致痴呆的疾病。很可能是阿尔茨海默病——非常、非常可能。
I say that on the websites they describe the Alzheimer's trajectory as three to four to 20 years. The neurologist disagrees-- eight to 10 to maybe, maybe 12. But, remember, he's had these symptoms for at least two, I'd say, three years. The neurologist makes clear that those eight to 10 to 12 years for Brian would be the end of life-- the end of his body's life.
我说，在网站上，他们将阿尔茨海默病的病程描述为三到四年，甚至长达20年。神经科医生不同意——八到十年，也许，也许12年。但是，记住，他说这些症状他已经有至少两年，我认为是三年了。神经科医生明确表示，布莱恩那八到十年甚至12年的时间，将是生命终结的时间——他身体寿命的终结。
I have now watched enough Alzheimer's diary videos-- who records this grief and posts it on YouTube; who does this, I think, even though I am as grateful as I am horrified-- that it's very clear that the end of the body will be long after the end of the self. By moving to the practical, the neurologist signals that we are coming to the end of the appointment.
我已经看了足够多的阿尔茨海默病日记视频——是谁在记录这种悲伤并把它发布在YouTube上；是谁在这么做，我想，尽管我既感激又恐惧——很明显，身体的终结将在自我的终结之后很久才到来。通过转入实际问题，神经科医生暗示我们的预约即将结束。
She says that Brian probably should not be driving even with the GPS and not because he'll get lost. "Because," Brian jumps in, "I might be in an accident." "You might kill someone," the neurologist says. We are both silent.
她说布莱恩可能不应该开车，即使有GPS导航，不是因为他会迷路。“因为，”布莱恩插话道，“我可能会出事故。”“你可能会杀人，”神经科医生说。我们俩都沉默了。
We get home, and we cry for an hour in each other's arms. We agree not to do much talking for 24 hours. Our whole weekend is crying and talking and binge-watching TV at night. I was sure that Brian had Alzheimer's before the MRI. I thought, it's not a surprise. But it was a surprise. The way every bad thing-- even as you see the flames in the distance, even as the terrible thing is upon you, breathing in your ear, hammering on your narrow bones-- is still a surprise.
我们回到家，在彼此的怀里哭了一个小时。我们同意24小时内不怎么说话。整个周末都在哭泣、谈话和晚上狂看电视。在做核磁共振之前，我就确定布莱恩患有阿尔茨海默病。我想，这并不意外。但它依然让我感到意外。就像每一件坏事——即使你看到远处的火光，即使可怕的事情已经降临，在你耳边呼吸，捶打着你脆弱的骨头——依然会让你感到意外。
Before we fall asleep, Brian muses aloud about his wish to control his death and how I will arrange that for him. He'd made up his mind after 48 hours and never wavered. We cried, and I agreed. And he said to me, "You go research it. You're so good at that stuff." Which meant that while I was looking up Exit International and The Hemlock Society and websites that would sell you both the plastic turkey bag and the helium machine for your own do-it-yourself suffocation, I was also researching how to get fentanyl and phenobarbital and sodium pentobarbital on the dark web.
入睡前，布莱恩大声沉思着他想要掌控自己死亡的愿望，以及我将如何为他安排这一切。他在48小时后就下定了决心，从未动摇过。我们哭了，我同意了。他对我说：“你去研究一下。你最擅长这些事情了。”这意味着当我正在查找“退出国际”和“锁眼协会”，以及那些会卖给你塑料火鸡袋和氦气机供你自制窒息手段的网站时，我还在研究如何通过暗网获取芬太尼、苯巴比妥和戊巴比妥钠。
I research at the public library-- not on the phone, not on my laptop. The internet tells me again and again not to search anything from my own computer and that if I need to know something, call, don't text, and don't use my own laptop.
我在公共图书馆进行研究——不是在手机上，不是在笔记本电脑上。互联网一再告诉我，不要用我自己的电脑搜索任何东西，如果需要知道什么，打个电话，不要发短信，不要使用我自己的笔记本电脑。
I was discovering the limits of my friends with medical degrees and the possibilities of carbon monoxide poisoning-- in your car, in your garage-- but it's become more iffy since 1975, when the car industry adjusted the CO emissions and then applied catalytic converters. Also, we don't have a garage.
我发现了我有医学学位的朋友们的局限性，以及一氧化碳中毒的可能性——在你的车里，在车库里——但自1975年汽车工业调整了一氧化碳排放并应用了催化转化器以来，这就变得更不可靠了。而且，我们没有车库。
Brian's dearest, oldest friend-- his fishing buddy since 1979-- says to Brian, "If you think you don't need to go right now, and you want to wait a while, I can just shoot you myself in a year or two in a field." Brian hugs him.
布莱恩最亲密、最老的朋友——他自1979年以来的钓鱼伙伴——对布莱恩说：“如果你认为现在不需要马上走，想等一等，一两年内我可以在田野里亲手解决你。”布莱恩拥抱了他。
I look up how it feels to drown. Lots of people have first-person accounts about near-drowning, and they seem divided between peaceful brain fog as the white light shines brighter and clawing one's terrified way through terrible suffocation. I mention that drowning is a way some people end their lives. Brian looks at me hard. "Are you kidding me? It's cold. No."
我查了溺水的感觉。很多人都有关于濒临溺水的第一人称记述，他们似乎分为两派：一派觉得当白光越来越亮时，大脑陷入宁静的迷雾；另一派则是通过恐怖的窒息感挣扎求生。我提到溺水是有些人结束生命的一种方式。布莱恩严厉地看着我。“你在开玩笑吗？那很冷。不。”
In the depths of Google wormholes for end of life, for assisted suicide, for euthanasia, for terminal illness, and for making end-of-life choices, in August, I finally find Dignitas, a Swiss organization to which even a foreigner can apply for an accompanied suicide if you meet their criteria-- be of sound mind, have medical records supporting this, have $10,000 to commit, and be sufficiently mobile to get to the outskirts of Zurich.
在八月份钻研谷歌关于临终、辅助自杀、安乐死、绝症和做出临终选择的深渊中，我终于找到了“尊严机构”，这是一个瑞士组织，如果符合他们的标准——头脑清醒，有医疗记录支持，投入一万美元，并且有足够的行动能力前往苏黎世郊区——即使是外国人也可以申请陪同自杀。
Fall 2019, Stony Creek. Applying to Dignitas is pretty much my second job now-- getting medical records from the distant past, an autobiographical essay from Brian, current dental records, his birth certificate. But every mistake I make ends up costing us two weeks.
2019年秋，石溪。申请“尊严机构”现在几乎是我的第二职业——从久远的过去获取医疗记录，布莱恩的一篇自传体文章，当前的牙科记录，他的出生证明。但我的每一个小错误最终都会让我们损失两周时间。
And the thing that takes up so much time is a careless note on a form from the neurologist that describes Brian as clinically depressed. He's not. But it's exactly the thing that Dignitas will not support. I have to find a psychiatrist who will certify that Brian meets all of Dignitas's criteria.
而最耗时的事情是神经科医生在表格上的一个草率注释，将布莱恩描述为患有临床抑郁症。他并没有。但这恰恰是“尊严机构”不会支持的情况。我必须找到一位精神科医生，证明布莱恩符合“尊严机构”的所有标准。
Brian is a certain kind of CEO for this project. He doesn't want to participate in discussions below his pay grade. He doesn't want to overhear troubling or puzzling discussions. He doesn't want any bad news. He doesn't want any unsolved problems presented, and regular progress reports are appreciated. No meeting should last more than 10 minutes.
布莱恩是这个项目的某种首席执行官。他不想参与他职权范围之下的讨论。他不想听到令人困扰或费解的谈论。他不想要任何坏消息。他不希望呈现任何未解决的问题，对定期进度报告表示赞赏。任何会议的时间都不应超过10分钟。
Occasionally, when we hit a speed bump of which he's aware, he says, "This is crazy. It's my life. I should get to decide how to end it." Most days he seems to feel that I've got the situation well in hand-- that the end is coming too soon, certainly, but not right around the corner, not before we can do sushi and a movie many more times, and that nothing bad will happen in the process which will unfold as we expect. This is not true-- that nothing bad will happen-- and, therefore, not comforting to me. It leaves me quite alone with reality. But the way he feels is exactly what I want for him.
偶尔，当我们遇到他知道的障碍时，他说：“这太疯狂了。这是我的生命。我应该有权决定如何结束它。”大多数日子里，他似乎觉得我把情况掌握得很好——结局肯定来得太早，但不是迫在眉睫，不是在我们还能多次一起吃寿司看电影之前，而且在这个过程中不会发生什么坏事，一切都会如我们所愿展开。这不是真的——不会发生坏事是不可能的——因此，这对我来说并不令人安慰。它让我独自面对现实。但他的这种感觉正是我想要给他的。
Talking with a friend, I rant about the American health care system, our refusal to let people die a dignified and comfortable death, the money made off suffering, the doctors unable to face their limits and meet the needs of their patients. Nobody can talk about it, I say. Nobody seems to know what they're doing. There is literally no treatment. The most advanced Alzheimer's research in the world says, eat fucking blueberries, get enough fucking sleep. My friend nods.
与一位朋友交谈时，我吐槽了美国的医疗体系，我们拒绝让人有尊严且舒适地死去，从痛苦中牟利，医生们无法面对自己的局限，无法满足病人的需求。我说，没有人能谈论它。似乎没有人知道他们在做什么。简直没有治疗方法。世界上最先进的阿尔茨海默病研究说，吃该死的蓝莓，睡够该死的觉。我的朋友点了点头。
End of November 2019, Stony Creek. It's the day before Thanksgiving, and Dignitas tells us we now have the provisional green light. This is the call we have been working toward since August. Brian hugs me hard because we have accomplished the thing we wanted to accomplish and done it together, and he loves teamwork.
2019年11月底，石溪。那是感恩节的前一天，“尊严机构”告诉我们，我们现在获得了临时绿灯。这是我们自八月以来一直为之努力的电话。布莱恩紧紧地拥抱了我，因为我们完成了我们想要完成的事情，而且是一起完成的，他热爱团队合作。
And then the light changes and dims. And I am in the world without him in it. He sees clearly the world going on without him, me alone in the kitchen and him not next to me. We cry in each other's arms, and, without speaking, we go right up to bed for a nap at 11:00 AM and only come down when the kids come through the door ready to start Thanksgiving prep.
然后光线变暗了。我身处一个没有他的世界。他清楚地看到了没有他的世界，我独自在厨房，他不在我身边。我们在彼此的怀里哭泣，没有说话，我们在上午11点直接上床睡了一觉，直到孩子们进门准备开始感恩节大餐的准备工作时才下来。
I start dropping things. I drop the ceramic pie weights onto the kitchen floor. I drop an entire open bottle of corn syrup into a bowl of butter and eggs. I burn the toast. I actually set one pie on fire in the oven and quadruple the amount of bourbon in the other so that no one who is not a Kentucky drunk could eat it.
我开始笨手笨脚。我把陶瓷馅饼重物掉在了厨房地板上。我把整瓶打开的玉米糖浆掉进了装有黄油和鸡蛋的碗里。我烤焦了吐司。我实际上在烤箱里烧坏了一个馅饼，并在另一个里放了四倍的波本威士忌，以至于除了肯塔基州的酒鬼之外，谁都吃不了。
Thanksgiving is done. Christmas is coming. And so is my mother-in-law. Brian and I already knew a lot about Alzheimer's from my mother-in-law's best friend of 50 years. Joanne, Yvonne's best friend, was an aunt to Brian, a regular dinner guest, formidably well-dressed in the Nancy Reagan mold, a great golfer, a devoted philanthropist to causes I reviled, and my mother-in-law's boon companion for movies, dinner, and drinks at the club.
感恩节结束了。圣诞节快到了。我的婆婆也要来了。布莱恩和我已经从我婆婆最好的50年朋友那里了解了很多关于阿尔茨海默病的信息。乔安妮，伊冯最好的朋友，是布莱恩的姨妈，经常来家里吃饭，穿着讲究，有南希·里根的风格，是个高尔夫高手，是我所鄙视的事业的忠实慈善家，也是我婆婆去看电影、吃饭和在俱乐部喝酒的好伴侣。
She had descended into Alzheimer's these last few years as if on an express. First, she complained about the cleaning lady. Then she complained about her occasional guests. Then she complained about her son. Then she complained that valuables were being moved to odd places and probably stolen.
她在过去几年里陷入了阿尔茨海默病，就像乘坐快车一样。起初，她抱怨清洁女工。然后她抱怨偶尔来的客人。然后她抱怨她的儿子。然后她抱怨贵重物品被移到了奇怪的地方，可能被偷了。
Then she could no longer navigate, not even on roads she'd driven for 50 years. Then she became violent and tearful, afraid of the terrible real and imaginary forces beyond her control. And then she didn't have the capacity to behave well in the communal dining room, or dress appropriately for the yoga class, or even to keep herself clean and get along with her health care aide.
然后她无法再辨认方向，即使是在她开了50年的路上。然后她变得暴力且爱哭，害怕那些无法控制的、真实的和想象中的可怕力量。然后她没有能力在公共餐厅表现良好，或者为瑜伽课做合适的装束，甚至无法保持自己整洁，与她的护理人员相处融洽。
Then her son moved her into a memory-care unit. And she still knew my mother-in-law and, weeping at every visit, begged her friend to take her home. Yvonne shared every detail of her dear friend's decline with Brian, who took note. I love my mother-in-law. Brian often quoted a favorite saying of hers, "We're not here for a long time. We're here for a good time." You can imagine how often he said that.
然后她的儿子把她送进了记忆护理中心。她依然认识我婆婆，每次探视都泪流满面，乞求她的朋友带她回家。伊冯与布莱恩分享了她亲爱的朋友衰退的每一个细节，布莱恩记在心上。我爱我的婆婆。布莱恩经常引用她的一句名言：“我们不是为了活得长，我们是为了活得开心。”你可以想象他说了多少次。
I hadn't said anything to Yvonne over the phone. Now I stand outside her bedroom door on our second floor until I hear bustling sounds. I knock, and she lets me in. She's already nicely put together. I sit on the bed beside her and tell her about our plan with Dignitas. She pulls away from me and wipes her eyes, and I wait with my hands clasped. I don't want a scene, but if there is one, I want it to happen while Brian is still asleep.
我在电话里没有对伊冯说任何话。现在我站在二楼她卧室门外，直到听到忙碌的声音。我敲了敲门，她让我进去。她已经打扮得很精致了。我坐在她身边的床上，告诉她我们和“尊严机构”的计划。她从我身边退开，擦了擦眼泪，我双手合十等待着。我不想闹出场景，但如果有的话，我希望是在布莱恩还在睡觉的时候发生。
Then she says, "I am so relieved. I realized that last night. I was praying about this and praying all night, and I realized that what I prayed for was that he would not have to suffer as Joanne does. I'm shocked that I'm so relieved. But I am." We hold hands and cry. And she says that I was a gift to her son. And I throw myself in her arms as if she is my own mother.
然后她说：“我感到如释重负。我昨晚意识到了。我一直在为这件事祈祷，整晚都在祈祷，我意识到我祈祷的是他不必像乔安妮那样受苦。我震惊自己竟然感到如此轻松。但我确实感到如此。”我们手拉手哭泣。她说我是她儿子的礼物。我扑进她的怀里，仿佛她就是我的亲生母亲。
December 2019, Stony Creek. I am practicing being a widow, preparing myself to do things alone, taking down the strings of lights by myself, listening to Brittany Howard, and having a snack. It is about as much like actual widowhood as our granddaughter Ivy making a fist and waving it overhead, saying ferociously, "When I do like this, I am magic, and you cannot catch me."
2019年12月，石溪。我正在练习做一个寡妇，准备自己做事情，独自取下灯串，听着布列塔尼·霍华德的歌，吃零食。这和真实的寡妇生活差不多，就像我们的孙女艾薇握着拳头在头顶挥舞，凶猛地说：“当我这样做时，我是魔法，你抓不住我。”
Monday, January 27, 2020, Zurich. We have an appointment with Dr. G at our hotel. As I understand it, Dr. G is both our guide through the process and a possible speed bump. The friend of a friend who'd brought her father with brain cancer to Dignitas told me that it was very important that Brian opened the hotel room door, showing that he's in charge of the process.
2020年1月27日，星期一，苏黎世。我们和G医生在我们酒店有一个预约。据我所知，G医生既是我们流程的向导，也是一个潜在的阻碍。那位带着患脑癌的父亲来到“尊严机构”的朋友告诉我，布莱恩亲自打开酒店房门非常重要，表明他掌控着这个过程。
I tell Brian this, and he nods. But I can tell he's not going to jump up at the first knock. Brian is not someone who rushes-- period-- to host at any gathering we've ever had. He loves being the guest, and he makes up for it by doing a ton of dishes after. I don't know how to make sure he answers the door or even if it's important. I just keep saying, "The doctor's going to knock on our hotel room door."
我告诉布莱恩这一点，他点了点头。但我看得出来他不会在第一次敲门时就跳起来。布莱恩从来不是一个在任何聚会上匆忙去迎接的人。他喜欢做客，并会通过事后洗一大堆盘子来弥补。我不知道如何确保他去开门，或者这是否重要。我只是不断说：“医生会敲我们酒店的房门。”
I'm also worried about etiquette. Will the doctor expect a cup of tea? Does he look like the grim reaper? No and no. The doctor does knock on the door, and I almost scream. Brian strolls over to the door and is his most amiable and pleasant Brian self. We used to say that Brian could talk to anyone. He could make small talk with a stump and, in the end, that stump would be hugging Brian goodbye, thanking him for a great evening, and inviting us all to the next stump get-together.
我也担心礼节。医生会期待一杯茶吗？他看起来像死神吗？不和不。医生确实敲了门，我差点尖叫出来。布莱恩慢悠悠地走到门口，表现出他最和蔼可亲的一面。我们过去常说布莱恩能和任何人交谈。他能和一个树桩聊天，最后那个树桩会和布莱恩拥抱告别，感谢他度过了一个美好的夜晚，并邀请我们所有人参加下一次树桩聚会。
Dr. G is a small man with large, lovely, mournful eyes. We all shake hands and Brian and Dr. G sit across from each other. I ask Dr. G if I can stay for the conversation, and he looks surprised. He says gently that, of course, I should stay as this all concerns me as well. I begin crying, and both men look at me kindly.
G医生是个身材矮小的男人，有着一双又大又可爱、忧伤的眼睛。我们都握了手，布莱恩和G医生坐在一起。我问G医生我是否可以留下来参加谈话，他看起来很惊讶。他温柔地说，当然可以，我应该留下，因为这一切也关乎我。我开始哭泣，两个男人都善意地看着我。
I pour myself a glass of water. Dr. G, "Moishe," he says-- that's my father's name, and I feel lightly blessed somehow, and I know that I have lost my mind-- asks about our flight.
我给自己倒了一杯水。G医生，“莫伊舍，”他说——那是我父亲的名字，我感到某种轻微的祝福，我知道我一定是疯了——他问起我们的飞行情况。
He mentions-- complaining lightly, just en passant, in what I can only describe as the Jewish fashion of complaining while assuring us at the beginning and end of each sentence that he is certainly not complaining-- that he had to come so late at night because he was at a concert in the city. And it was most convenient coming after the concert because he lives by the lake and doesn't come into town every day. But since we chose to stay in the Old Town, he had to make a special trip just to see us, not that he's complaining.
他提到——轻微地抱怨，顺带一提，用我只能描述为那种犹太式的抱怨风格，同时在每句话的开头和结尾向我们保证他肯定不是在抱怨——他不得不这么晚来，是因为他在城里听了一场音乐会。而且在音乐会之后来非常方便，因为他住在湖边，不是每天都进城。但既然我们选择住在老城区，他不得不为了见我们特地跑一趟，并不是说他在抱怨。
I beg him to take a glass of water, and he does, probably so I'll stop crying. He opens a folder and says to Brian, "After I read your application, I knew I would see you, but I didn't think it would be this soon." Brian says, "It's not a big window. I mean, no one knows how long they have, how much time they have to make this choice." Dr. G looks like he might argue, but instead he says, "You're absolutely right."
我恳求他喝一杯水，他喝了，大概是为了让我停止哭泣。他打开一个文件夹，对布莱恩说：“在读了你的申请后，我知道我会见到你，但我没想到会这么快。”布莱恩说：“窗口期并不大。我是说，没人知道他们有多少时间，有多少时间来做这个选择。”G医生看起来可能要争论，但他却说：“你说得完全对。”
He says to Brian, "I will ask you several times-- many times-- if you are sure that this is what you wish to do. And I want you to understand that at any time-- at any time between now and the final act-- you are free to change your mind and not do this. I hope you will not do this," he says softly. And Brian nods. "So," Dr. G says, "are you sure that you wish to end your life on Thursday?" Brian says that he is sure.
他对布莱恩说：“我会问你几次——很多次——你是否确定这是你想要做的。我想让你明白，在任何时候——从现在到最后的那一刻之前的任何时候——你都有自由改变主意，不去做这件事。我希望你不要这样做，”他轻声说。布莱恩点了点头。“那么，”G医生说，“你确定你想在周四结束你的生命吗？”布莱恩说他确定。
I start crying again, and, thank God, both men ignore me again. Dr. G smiles and nods. "It seems to me," he says pleasantly, holding up the folder, "you don't believe in anything, Mr. Ameche." Brian laughs and says, "I believe in a lot of things, but religion and the afterlife are not among them." "Well," Dr. G says, chuckling, "you'll find out before I will. Let me know." Brian smiles.
我又开始哭泣，谢天谢地，两个男人又忽略了我。G医生微笑着点点头。“在我看来，”他愉快地握着文件夹说，“你不相信任何东西，阿米奇先生。”布莱恩大笑起来，说：“我相信很多东西，但宗教和来世不在其中。”“好吧，”G医生笑着说，“你会比我先知道的。告诉我一声。”布莱恩微笑着。
Dr. G's tone changes. "Let me tell you what will happen. You will arrive at our apartment building in the suburbs of Zurich in the morning by 10:00 AM. Do not be late. You will be greeted by two people from Dignitas. They will invite you in. You can take your time," he says.
G医生的语气变了。“让我告诉你将会发生什么。你将在上午10点之前到达我们位于苏黎世郊区的公寓大楼。不要迟到。会有两名来自‘尊严机构’的人接待你。他们会邀请你进去。你可以慢慢来，”他说。
"There will be no rushing. There is some paperwork. There are chocolates. They will give you an anti-emetic," he says, "so you will not vomit. You have up to an hour after that to make your choice about drinking the drink. If you need more time, they will administer the anti-emetic again. And, again, you will have about an hour after that to drink the drink. After you drink it, it is a little bitter," he says. And I wonder how he knows.
“不会有催促。有一些文书工作。有巧克力。他们会给你一种止吐药，”他说，“这样你就不会呕吐。在那之后，你有长达一个小时的时间来做出是否喝下饮料的选择。如果你需要更多时间，他们会再次提供止吐药。同样，在那之后，你会有大约一个小时的时间来喝下饮料。在你喝下它之后，它是有点苦的，”他说。我不禁想他是怎么知道的。
"After you drink it, you will fall into a light sleep, then a deep sleep. Then it will be over. Mrs. Ameche, you can sit with him for a long time." I'm glad he calls me Mrs. Ameche. I know Brian always gets a kick out of that. Brian nods attentively. Dr. G says, "At any time in this process, you may change your mind-- right now or Thursday morning. No one will be surprised or distressed. We'll all be glad for you."
“在你喝下它之后，你会陷入浅睡，然后是深睡。然后一切就结束了。阿米奇太太，你可以陪他坐很长一段时间。”我很高兴他叫我阿米奇太太。我知道布莱恩总是对此感到兴奋。布莱恩专心地听着，点了点头。G医生说：“在这个过程中的任何时候，你都可以改变主意——现在或周四早上。没人会感到惊讶或痛苦。我们都会为你感到高兴。”
I don't know why this would be. Perhaps I would be glad, too, but only if it meant the spell was broken, and my whole husband was returned to me and to himself, and these last years turned out to have been just a terrible test-- one poisoned apple after another-- to prove that my darling deserves the life he had before. Brian shakes his head. "I know what I'm doing," he says. "This is the right thing for me." Dr. G nods. "I see that," he says, "but I will keep asking."
我不知道为什么会这样。也许我也会感到高兴，但只有当这意味着咒语被打破，我整个丈夫回归我身边，回归他自己，而过去这些年只不过是一场可怕的测试——一个接一个的毒苹果——为了证明我亲爱的值得他曾经拥有的生活。布莱恩摇了摇头。“我知道我在做什么，”他说。“这对我是正确的事情。”G医生点点头。“我看得出来，”他说，“但我会继续问的。”
Brian and I sit back down after he's gone. I say that Dr. G seemed nice, and Brian agrees. Brian says, "It's going OK," and I agree. We sleep side-by-side, fingertips touching.
他走后，布莱恩和我坐回原处。我说G医生看起来很不错，布莱恩也同意。布莱恩说：“事情进行得很顺利，”我也同意。我们并肩睡去，指尖触碰在一起。
Thursday, January 30, 2020, Zurich. The night passes, and the next morning we have a car take us to Pfaffikon, where Dignitas has its apartment or house. I couldn't really tell. It's a residential structure in an industrial park. Two nice women in nice clothes, sweaters and slacks-- I mean, I feel that an effort was made; they didn't just throw on their sweats and come over-- greet us. They have dressed for the occasion of shepherding us across the river, and they take it seriously.
2020年1月30日，星期四，苏黎世。夜晚过去，第二天早上，我们乘车前往法菲孔，那里有“尊严机构”的公寓或房子。我真说不准。那是一个工业园区里的住宅建筑。两名穿着得体、穿着毛衣和休闲裤的好心女士——我的意思是，我感觉到她们确实做出了努力；她们不是随便套上运动衫就过来的——接待了我们。她们为引领我们渡河这一场合进行了着装，她们非常认真。
I have never been treated with such seamless, attentive tact. They walk us in, up a few steps to the door-- and I see a snow-covered garden, the kind of gesture toward a garden that you'd find in an industrial park-- and into a large, odd, immaculate room. There's seating in every corner-- two small armchairs, a large pleather recliner, a pleather sofa, and a hospital bed as well. It dawns on me later that it's important that everything that can be sat on or laid down upon be washable.
我从未受到过如此天衣无缝、周到体贴的对待。她们带我们走进去，顺着几级台阶来到门口——我看到一个被雪覆盖的花园，那种你在工业园区里会发现的对花园的致意——进入一个很大、奇怪、一尘不染的房间。每个角落都有座位——两把小扶手椅、一个大皮质躺椅、一个皮质沙发，还有一张病床。后来我才明白，重要的是所有能坐或躺的东西都必须是可清洗的。
In the center of the room, there's a table with several chairs. The ladies bring our paperwork to the table and point out the many bowls of chocolates. They review all of the steps, which Brian and I can now both recite. They look at him closely and say, "At any time in this process, including after you drink the anti-emetic, you can choose not to do this. We'll be very supportive of you changing your mind, rest assured." We are assured.
房间中央有一张桌子和几把椅子。女士们把我们的文书带到桌边，指出了几碗巧克力。她们复习了所有的步骤，布莱恩和我现在都能背诵了。她们仔细观察他，说：“在这个过程中的任何时候，包括你喝下止吐药之后，你都可以选择不做这件事。如果你改变主意，我们会非常支持你，请放心。”我们放心了。
The only sign of reluctance on Brian's part is what he warned me about-- is making conversation before taking the sodium pentobarbital. He said to me that he thought he might be inclined to just bullshit around for a while when the time came to take it. "I know I have to go," he said. "I know I'm going. I'm ready. I'm just not going to hurry."
布莱恩唯一表现出勉强的地方是他警告过我的——就是在喝下戊巴比妥钠之前进行交谈。他对我说，他觉得当轮到喝药时，他可能倾向于随意闲聊一会儿。“我知道我必须走，”他说。“我知道我要走了。我准备好了。我只是不会匆忙。”
He doesn't hurry. He drinks the anti-emetic and gets comfortable on the couch. I sit next to him holding his hand, but I have to let it go because he's gesturing while storytelling.
他不匆忙。他喝下止吐药，在沙发上调整到舒适的姿势。我坐在他身边握着他的手，但我不得不松开它，因为他在讲故事时在打手势。
The stories are all about football at Yale and his coach, Carm Cozza, and I could tell them with him-- Brian and a friend winding up in jail because of a young, dumb fight in front of the Anchor Bar and Carm Cozza, stern and forgiving, bailing them out; Brian talking about quitting football because he didn't get to play enough his first season, and Carm telling him that he, Carm, would let Brian play when Brian was good enough and not before, and Brian resolving to be good enough; Brian's father and Carm Cozza playing handball together one time, his two fathers.
故事全都是关于耶鲁的橄榄球和他的教练卡姆·科扎的，我能和他一起讲出来——布莱恩和一个朋友因为在安克酒吧前发生了一场年轻、愚蠢的斗殴而最终进了监狱，卡姆·科扎严厉又宽容地把他们保释出来；布莱恩谈论因为第一赛季没机会上场而想退出橄榄球队，卡姆告诉他，等布莱恩足够优秀时他自然会让他上场，绝不会提前，于是布莱恩决心变得足够优秀；布莱恩的父亲和卡姆·科扎曾经一起玩手球，他的两位父亲。
I cannot manage to look interested in these stories because I'm not. Brian says nothing about his life, about our life, about our love, about the children and grandchildren, nothing about the beautiful public housing he designed and cared about so deeply, or the work he did for conservation and open spaces, or even-- and you know I must be reaching here-- about fishing. But I do try not to look like I'm in agony, which I am.
我无法表现出对这些故事感兴趣，因为我并不感兴趣。布莱恩什么也没说，没谈他的生活，没谈我们的生活，没谈我们的爱，没谈孩子和孙辈，没谈他设计且深切关心的美丽公共住房，或者他为保护自然和开放空间所做的工作，甚至——你知道我这肯定是强求了——关于钓鱼。但我确实尽量看起来不像是在痛苦之中，尽管我确实如此。
The ladies wait in the back room-- a kitchen, I think-- and after about 45 minutes, they come out again. They tell us that the anti-emetic has now worn off and if Brian wishes to continue-- "I do," he says-- he will have to take it again. They say, "You can take your time." And I roll my eyes because of course he will. He always does, I think, as if we are in some other room, on some other occasion, and then I remember where I am, and I am ashamed of myself.
女士们在后屋等待——我想是厨房——大约45分钟后，她们又出来了。她们告诉我们止吐药现在失效了，如果布莱恩希望继续——“我愿意，”他说——他必须再吃一次。她们说：“你可以慢慢来。”我翻了个白眼，因为他当然会慢慢来。他总是这样，我想，仿佛我们是在某个其他房间，在某种其他场合，然后我记得我是在哪里，我为自己感到羞耻。
Brian smiles slightly. "What time's your plane?" he says, and I have never felt so bad about being me in my entire life. He takes the anti-emetic again, and the ladies put an airplane pillow around his neck. Brian falls silent, and now I long for the football stories. I take both of his hands, and he lets me. "I love you. I love you. I love you," I say. "I love you so much." "I love you, too," he says, and he drinks the sodium pentobarbital. I kiss him all over his handsome, weary face, and he lets me.
布莱恩微微一笑。“你的飞机几点？”他说，我一生中从未因为成为自己而感到如此糟糕。他再次服下止吐药，女士们在他的脖子上放了一个飞机枕。布莱恩沉默了，现在我渴望听到那些橄榄球故事。我握住他的双手，他任由我握着。“我爱你。我爱你。我爱你，”我说。“我太爱你了。”“我也爱你，”他说，然后他喝下了戊巴比妥钠。我吻遍了他英俊但疲惫的面孔，他任由我吻着。
It is impossible to think about the next 20 minutes. I keep my eyes and hands on him as if I'll forget what it is like to breathe next to him or feel his presence. I don't-- not for a minute. I hear his breathing when I go to sleep, and I feel his body heat when I wake up. He falls asleep holding my hand, and his head falls back a little on the neck pillow, whose purpose I now understand.
去思考接下来的20分钟是不可能的。我把眼睛和手放在他身上，仿佛我会忘记在他身边呼吸或感受他存在的感觉。我不会——哪怕一分钟也不会。我睡觉时能听到他的呼吸，醒来时能感受到他的体温。他握着我的手睡着了，他的头在颈枕上微微后仰，我终于理解了那个枕头的用途。
His breathing changes, and it's the last time I will hear him sleeping, breathing deeply and steadily, the way he has done lying beside me for almost 15 years. I hold his hand. I can still feel its weight and warmth. His skin color changes from ruddy to paler pink. I sit there and sit there as if some other thing will now happen. He is quite pale, and I see that he has gone from this world.
他的呼吸改变了，这是我最后一次听到他睡觉、深沉而平稳地呼吸，就像他过去近15年来躺在我身边一样。我握着他的手。我依然能感觉到它的重量和温度。他的肤色从红润变得苍白。我坐在那里，坐了又坐，仿佛还有什么其他事情要发生。他脸色相当苍白，我看出他已经离开了这个世界。
I sit holding his hand for a long time. I get up and wrap my arms around him and kiss his forehead, as if he is my baby, at last gone to sleep, as if he is my brave boy going on a long journey miles and miles of Nought.
我坐着握他的手坐了很久。我起身拥抱他，亲吻他的额头，仿佛他终于睡着的婴儿，仿佛他是我的勇敢男孩，即将踏上前往虚无之地的漫长旅程。
There's not much else to do. The ladies would like me to go before the Swiss police come. It is simpler, they say. It doesn't feel that we have done something illegal, but I can tell that it would be better-- perhaps better for me, for Dignitas-- for me to not be around while a Swiss policeman identifies Brian's body. That's what his passport and dental records are for, as I understand it.
没别的事可做了。女士们希望我在瑞士警察来之前离开。她们说这样更简单。这感觉不像我们做了什么非法的事，但我可以说，如果我不在现场，让瑞士警察确认布莱恩的尸体，这会更好——也许对我、对“尊严机构”更好。据我所知，他的护照和牙科记录就是为了这个。
I call an Uber and hug the ladies. I head to the airport. In the Zurich airport, I sit in the fancy lounge, and I look around for faces, people watching. Since the moment of Brian's death, I find most people, especially men, disgusting-- not just unappealing, but disgusting, like yesterday's oatmeal, like eels in a bowl. I find heterosexual couples dismaying.
我叫了一辆优步，拥抱了女士们。我前往机场。在苏黎世机场，我坐在高级贵宾室里，四处寻找面孔，观察人们。从布莱恩去世的那一刻起，我发现大多数人，尤其是男人，令人作呕——不仅仅是不吸引人，而是令人作呕，像昨天的燕麦粥，像碗里的鳗鱼。我发现异性恋伴侣令我沮丧。
In the lounge, I feel like an alien examining pairs of earthlings. What is the meaning of that? How could a creature like that be the choice this other creature makes? How can one recognize choice in these random movements?
在贵宾室里，我感觉自己像个正在审视一对对地球生物的外星人。那意味着什么？像那样的一个生物怎么会是这另一个生物所做的选择？人们怎么能在这些随机的动作中识别出选择？
September 15, 2007, Durham, Connecticut. Our wedding day. My mother isn't there to see it, and that is my only grief. The last time she was in the hospital, Brian dropped me off and went to park. My mother waved me into her room and kissed me. "Is Brian coming up?" she said. When I said, "Yes," she practically pushed me off the bed and began firmly and pleasantly directing me in how best to help her-- bed jacket, comb, blush, and lipstick, please. Hairspray-- hurry, please.
2007年9月15日，康涅狄格州达勒姆。我们的婚礼那天。我的母亲没能看到它，这是我唯一的遗憾。她最后一次住院时，布莱恩把我放下，去停车了。我母亲向我招手让我进病房，亲吻了我。“布莱恩上来了吗？”她说。当我说是的时候，她几乎把我从床上推开，坚定而愉快地指挥我如何最好地帮助她——睡袍、梳子、腮红和口红，拜托。发胶——快点，拜托。
By the time Brian came to her door, she was in full Greer Garson and sent me to get tea for both of them. Oh, she would have said over breakfast on our wedding day, isn't this lovely? Aren't you gorgeous? Isn't he the handsomest thing?
当布莱恩来到她门前时，她正处于格里尔·加森的全力状态，派我去给他们俩泡茶。噢，她在我们婚礼当天的早餐时会说，这不是很可爱吗？你不漂亮吗？他不是最英俊的东西吗？
Friends from all pieces of our lives are there-- some neighbors who disapproved of our scandalous beginnings and come around. We had both been with other people. We didn't behave well. We fell in love and left our partners. We didn't slink out of town, and we glowed like radium.
我们生活中各处的朋友都在那里——一些曾不赞同我们丑闻式开端的邻居也来了。我们俩都曾和别人在一起。我们表现得并不好。我们坠入爱河，离开了伴侣。我们没有悄悄溜出城，我们像镭一样闪闪发光。
Our minister speaks wisely and warmly, and I am delighted, but I barely listen. Brian takes my hands, and I cannot see anything except his face. He says, "I prepared some," and then he squeezes my hands tightly, and he begins to cry. "I love you so much," he says. "That's all I can say. I love you so, so much. And I will love you every day of my life." Then he says, quietly, "Your turn."
我们的牧师说话既睿智又热情，我很高兴，但我几乎没听。布莱恩握住我的手，除了他的脸，我什么也看不见。他说：“我准备了一些，”然后他紧紧地握住我的手，开始哭泣。“我太爱你了，”他说。“我只能说这些。我太爱你了，太爱你了。我余生的每一天都会爱你。”然后他轻声说：“该你了。”
I say, "Middle-aged women are supposed to look for the safe harbor, for the port in the storm of life. We are supposed to look for the calm and the comfortable. You are the port in the storm. And you are the storm. And you are the sea. You are the rocks and the beach and the waves. You are the sunrise and the sunset and all of the light in between."
我说：“中年女性应该寻找安全的港湾，寻找人生的风雨避风港。我们应该寻找平静和舒适。你就是风雨中的避风港。你就是风暴。你就是大海。你是岩石、沙滩和海浪。你是日出和日落，以及其间所有的光芒。”
I think I have more to say, but I can't. We are holding hands, pressed against each other, holding each other up. I whisper to him, "Every day of my life." And he whispers to me, "Every day of my life."
我想我还有更多话要说，但我说不出。我们手拉手，紧贴着彼此，支撑着彼此。我对他耳语：“我余生的每一天。”他对我耳语：“我余生的每一天。”
Amy Bloom. Some of the audio you heard was excerpted from the official audiobook of In Love by Amy bloom, narrated by the author, courtesy of the Penguin Random House Audio Group.
艾米·布鲁姆。你刚才听到的部分音频摘自艾米·布鲁姆的《In Love》官方有声读物，由作者本人朗读，由企鹅兰登书屋有声读物集团授权。
If you happen to be having thoughts of suicide, please reach out to the National Suicide Prevention Lifeline at 988 or the Crisis Text Line. For that, you text talk-- T-A-L-K-- to 741741. Coming up-- jokes that are not entirely jokes that a mother tells about her daughter. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
如果你恰好有自杀的念头，请拨打国家自杀预防生命线988或危机短信专线。你可以发短信“talk”到741741。接下来——一位母亲讲述关于女儿的玩笑，有些玩笑并不完全是玩笑。节目继续，请稍后收听芝加哥公共广播。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program-- "Ends of the Earth," stories about the very upper limits of what you do for somebody you love, of people going way further than you usually see for their family members. We have arrived at Act Two of our program-- Act Two, Comedy Duo.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目——“地球尽头”，讲述关于你为所爱之人所能做出的极限行为，人们为了家庭成员所走得比你通常看到的远得多。我们已经进入节目的第二幕——第二幕，喜剧二人组。
Zoya is in college, but she and her mom, Zarna, are really, really close, talking and texting every day about the most mundane stuff, like what they're eating for lunch. But they deal with the big stuff too.
卓娅在上大学，但她和妈妈扎娜非常、非常亲近，每天都会谈论和发短信讨论最琐碎的事情，比如她们午餐吃什么。但她们也处理大事。
Because we are each other's only people, to be honest. Like, she doesn't have anyone else, and I don't have anyone else. Like, we don't have a lot of extended family.
因为老实说，我们是彼此唯一的人。就像，她没有别人，我也没有别人。就像，我们没有什么大家庭。
Well, she's married.
好吧，她结婚了。
She is married. I mean, yeah, people always say that.
她是结婚了。我是说，是的，人们总是这么说。
[LAUGHS]
（笑声）
So I think that what's-- yeah. Sorry, Dad. [LAUGHS] She is married. They get along really well. My dad is very traditional. Parenting decisions are made solely by her and supported by my dad.
所以我认为——是的。抱歉，爸爸。（笑声）她是结婚了。他们相处得非常好。我爸爸非常传统。育儿决定完全由她做出，并得到我爸爸的支持。
Right.
对。
So my mom and I are like our own little, like, 2 by 2 unit.
所以我和我妈就像是我们自己的小单位。
But ever since Zoya went away to college-- 3,000 miles from her mom-- they've been fighting more than ever, mainly because at her school, Stanford University, for the first time, Zoya realized that kids her age, her peers, were making decisions, even big ones, without consulting their moms.
但自从卓娅去上大学——离她妈妈3000英里远——她们吵架吵得比以前多得多，主要是因为在她的学校，斯坦福大学，卓娅第一次意识到，像她这个年纪的孩子，她的同龄人，在不咨询他们妈妈的情况下做出决定，甚至是大决定。
Which was a huge-- I mean, that really took me aback. I was like, wow.
这对我来说是一个巨大的打击——我是说，那真的让我感到惊讶。我当时想，哇。
If Zoya could make her own choices at college without her mom-- well, she loves the arts, painting, writing. An essay of hers was published in The New York Times. Her mom, Zarna, is like, sure, a little of that.
如果卓娅能在大学里不带她妈妈做出自己的选择——嗯，她热爱艺术，绘画，写作。她的一篇文章发表在《纽约时报》上。她妈妈扎娜觉得，当然，可以尝试一点点。
One class for fun-- like, fine, take something. It's OK. I'll live with that. But the overwhelming focus needs to be on something-- science, tech, engineering, math-- that's going to lead to a job--
为了乐趣上一门课——好吧，可以，上点什么课都没问题。但我会接受的。但绝大部分精力需要放在某些东西上——科学、技术、工程、数学——那会带来一份工作——
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
--and pay for this degree that's going to cost us a bomb and justify being at Stanford. Like, oh, she's taking an English class-- that her professor loved her. And he told her-- he's like, "You're such a strong writer. I hope we don't lose you to the computer people."
——并支付这个花掉我们要命钱的学位，并证明在斯坦福的合理性。就像，噢，她正在上一门英语课——她的教授很喜欢她。他告诉她——他说：“你是一位非常有力的作家。我希望我们不会失去你，落入那些计算机人的手中。”
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
And when she told me that, I was like, oh, my God, these people are everywhere.
当她告诉我这些时，我当时想，噢，天哪，这些人到处都是。
[LAUGHS]
（笑声）
I was so scared.
我太害怕了。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
These people are trying to ruin your child's life.
这些人正试图毁了你孩子的生活。
They're, like, trying to ruin her life. What is happening? [CHUCKLES]
他们试图毁了她的生活。发生了什么？（轻笑）
Can I just say-- like, before we go further, my mom would definitely relate to this. My mom was so sure that I should be a doctor. And then when I went into radio and broadcasting, she was so disappointed. And she continued to tell me, there's still time to go to medical school. Like, I had my own national radio show. I was on the air for five years. And I remember it was finally-- I was 41 years old, and it was only because I went on to David Letterman for the first time--
我能说一句吗——就像，在我们进一步深入之前，我妈妈肯定会对此产生共鸣。我妈妈非常确定我应该成为一名医生。然后当我进入广播行业时，她非常失望。她继续告诉我，现在去医学院还来得及。就像，我有自己的全国广播节目。我在广播里做了五年。我记得最终——我当时41岁，只是因为我第一次上了大卫·莱特曼的节目——
[LAUGHS]
（笑声）
--to promote the show-- that after the Letterman appearance, my mom said, like, OK, you win.
——为了宣传这个节目——在大卫·莱特曼露面之后，我妈妈说，好吧，你赢了。
[LAUGHS]
（笑声）
You don't have to go to medical school. But for that entire time, she was very-- [CHUCKLES] she was very-- I think I have a lot to relate to with Zoya. She's like, why are you doing this thing? It doesn't make any money. Why? You could be a doctor. Like, you're smart. You could be a doctor.
你不需要去读医学院。但在那整个时间里，她非常——（轻笑）她非常——我觉得我和卓娅有很多相似之处。她就像，你为什么要在这事儿上折腾？这赚不到钱。为什么？你本可以成为一名医生。就像，你很聪明。你本可以成为一名医生。
Exactly. Listen. There's-- I don't want to say it, but there's a part of me right now that's thinking you should take the MCAT.
正是如此。听着。有一部分我——我不想说出来，但有一部分我此刻在想你应该去考医学院入学考试。
[LAUGHS]
（笑声）
I don't know. Maybe the quality of that joke tips you off. Zarna is a stand-up comedian-- Zarna Garg, kind of a rising star right now. She just filmed her first comedy special. She's huge on TikTok, plays the rooms in New York City that the most famous headliners do. And what makes her act so unusual is that it is happily, almost giddily, from her point of view as an immigrant mom born in India. Here she is telling an audience about something she truly did not know about college in America till Zoya got to Stanford.
我不知道。也许那个玩笑的质量让你有所觉察。扎娜是一位单口喜剧演员——扎娜·加格，现在算是冉冉升起的明星。她刚刚拍摄了她的第一部喜剧特辑。她在TikTok上非常火，在纽约市最著名的头条艺人表演的场所演出。让她的表演与众不同的是，她快乐地、几乎是轻快地站在作为一个出生在印度的移民母亲的角度。她在向观众讲述她真正不知道的关于美国的大学生活，直到卓娅进入斯坦福。
I have uncovered the world's biggest scam. Did you guys know that in this country the parents don't get to decide what the kid's going to study?
我发现了世界上最大的骗局。你们知道在这个国家，父母不能决定孩子学习什么吗？
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
You knew this?
你们知道这个？
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
You guys all knew this? No. I really thought when my kid goes to college, I will call the college up, and I will say, "Com Sci One, Com Sci Two, go."
你们全都知道这个？不。我真的以为当我的孩子去上大学时，我会给大学打电话，我会说，“计算机科学一，计算机科学二，去吧。”
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
She wants to have fun. I understand that. Give her one class in chemistry.
她想要玩得开心。我理解这一点。给她上一门化学课吧。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
She tells the audience about the fun non-computer class that her daughter wanted to take at Stanford.
她告诉观众她女儿想在斯坦福上的有趣的非计算机课。
Ceramics.
陶艺。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
[APPLAUSE]
（掌声）
$80,000 to learn how to make clay pots! Do you know who else makes clay pots? Villagers in India!
花八万美元去学习怎么做粘土罐！你们知道谁还做粘土罐吗？印度的村民！
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
Because they have nothing else to do.
因为他们没别的事可做。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
My kid is in Palo Alto, the epicenter of technology, making clay pots.
我的孩子在帕洛阿尔托，技术的中心，在做粘土罐。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
Zarna's entire act is this tricky thing of embracing every stereotype of the immigrant Indian mom while also kind of-- I don't know-- winking at the audience like, I know this is over the top. I know how funny this is. She does this bit about telling Zoya not to become friends with kids at Stanford who might pull her down the wrong path.
扎娜的整场表演是一种棘手的技巧，拥抱移民印度母亲的每一个刻板印象，同时也——我不知道——给观众抛去一个眼神，就像，我知道这太夸张了。我知道这有多好笑。她做了一个关于告诉卓娅不要在斯坦福与那些可能把她拖入歧途的孩子交朋友的段子。
You cannot be friends with any communications majors--
你不可以和任何传播学专业的学生做朋友——
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
--no kids who do music, no kids who do drama. Recruited athletes-- do I even have to say it?
——没有搞音乐的孩子，没有搞戏剧的孩子。被招募的运动员——我甚至需要说出来吗？
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
OK. So this is both a joke, and it really happened. At a cafe one day, she told Zoya the kinds of majors that she might look for when she makes friends at school.
好的。所以这既是一个笑话，也是真的发生了。有一天在咖啡馆，她告诉卓娅当她在学校交朋友时可以寻找的专业。
You know, I thought she was joking. I mean, when she first said it, I cracked up. I was like, Mom, you are so hilarious. And she was like, why are you laughing?
你知道，我以为她在开玩笑。我是说，当她第一次说的时候，我笑喷了。我当时说，妈，你太搞笑了。她当时说，你为什么在笑？
So her mom is joking on stage, and it's real. To get where her mom Zarna is coming from on all this, some background-- probably the pivotal moment in Zarna's life was when she was 14, back in India. Her mom died. And this completely crushed her dad. Zarna was the youngest of four kids, and he didn't want to keep raising one last child. He wanted to get her married off as soon as possible.
所以她妈妈在舞台上开玩笑，而现实中也确实如此。为了理解她妈妈扎娜在这一切背后的出发点，一些背景——扎娜生命中枢纽的时刻可能是她14岁的时候，在印度。她妈妈去世了。这彻底摧毁了她父亲。扎娜是四个孩子中最小的一个，他不想再抚养最后一个孩子。他想尽快把她嫁出去。
And I didn't want to get married. I was that kid who was so curious and loved education and wanted to read about the world. And also, I was heavily influenced by American pop culture. I read Archie's comics. I watched Three's Company. You know that TV show?
而且我不想结婚。我就是那个既好奇又热爱教育，想要阅读世界各地知识的孩子。而且，我深受美国流行文化的影响。我读过《阿奇漫画》。我看过《三人行》。你知道那个电视节目吗？
Of course,
当然。
I was like, no one's married. They're all just living with everybody, seems fine.
我当时想，没人在结婚。他们都在和大家一起生活，看起来没问题。
She said no to marriage. Her dad kicked her out, and she had to make her own way in the world. She remembers standing out in the rain in front of the US embassy, who would not accept her paperwork to come here. She finally made it here, got a law degree, placed an ad to find exactly the kind of husband she wanted, which is a whole other story.
她拒绝了婚姻。她父亲把她赶了出去，她不得不在这世界上开辟自己的道路。她记得自己站在美国大使馆外的雨中，他们不接受她来这里的申请材料。她最终来到了这里，获得了法律学位，登广告寻找她想要的丈夫，那是另一个故事了。
And since then, she has devoted herself completely to her three kids to get them to a life that is safe and secure and very unlike her own teenage life. Zoya is the oldest, the pilot project. And for Zoya, this has meant just years of math camps and tutoring every summer and volunteer jobs that her mom arranged and after-school activities-- all, you know, to get her into a good college and, ultimately, a safe, comfortable job in tech or engineering or maybe medicine, which went great when Zoya was at home in high school.
从那以后，她把全部精力奉献给了她的三个孩子，让他们过上一种安全、有保障的生活，这与她自己的青少年生活截然不同。卓娅是最大的，是试点项目。对于卓娅来说，这意味着多年的数学夏令营和暑期补习，以及她妈妈安排的志愿者工作和课后活动——所有这些，你知道，都是为了让她进入一所好的大学，并最终在科技、工程或医学领域获得一份安全、舒适的工作。这在卓娅在家里上高中时进行得很顺利。
But now, at Stanford, threats to this plan are just everywhere. One of the biggest threats-- this American idea that at college, kids should explore, take the classes they enjoy, find what makes them happy.
但现在，在斯坦福，对这一计划的威胁无处不在。最大的威胁之一——这种美国的观念，即在大学里，孩子们应该探索，选择他们喜欢的课程，找到让他们快乐的事情。
As a parent, the happiness of my child is the last thing on my mind.
作为一名家长，孩子的幸福是我最不关心的事情。
Again, she delivers it like a punch line. It's totally over the top, but, also, she's not kidding.
同样，她像讲笑话一样说出来。这太夸张了，但也确实不是在开玩笑。
It's the last thing right now with me. I mean, eating candy makes a kid happy, but I don't give it to them.
这对我来说目前是最后考虑的事情。我是说，吃糖果会让孩子快乐，但我不会给他们吃。
Do you feel like she's being tricked into thinking happiness is important?
你觉得她被骗了，认为幸福很重要吗？
By people in America?
被美国人？
Yeah.
对。
Yeah, absolutely, 100%.
是的，绝对，100%。
100% is something Zarna says to a bunch of my questions. Does she know what's best for her family?
100%是扎娜对我的许多问题都会说的答案。她知道什么对她的家庭最好吗？
Yes, 100%.
是的，100%。
Does she think her children would thank her one day for forcing the hard decisions for their lives that they might not like just now?
她认为她的孩子们将来有一天会感谢她，因为她强迫他们做出生活中那些他们现在可能不喜欢的艰难决定吗？
100%.
100%。
So with this in mind, Zarna is still trying to control Zoya's life from the other side of the country to a remarkable extent. Like, for instance, she texts the RA in Zoya's dorm to check on Zoya's room, to make sure she's working. She has various people that she knows or just meets call Zoya to give encouraging pep talks about how great a life in computers or medicine is going to be.
所以考虑到这一点，扎娜仍在试图从国家的另一端控制卓娅的生活，程度惊人。比如，她给卓娅宿舍的宿管发短信询问卓娅的房间，确保她在学习。她有各种认识的或刚见到的人打电话给卓娅，给予鼓励，谈论在计算机或医学领域生活会有多美好。
She consults with Zoya on pretty much every aspect of her life. This impulse to control her daughter is so instinctive and thorough that, after I interviewed Zarna, Zarna called Zoya, who I hadn't interviewed just yet, with instructions on what to say to me.
她几乎在生活的每一个方面都与卓娅商量。这种控制女儿的冲动是如此本能且彻底，以至于在我采访完扎娜后，扎娜打电话给卓娅（我还没采访她），告诉她该对我说什么。
Well, she just said-- she just said, "When they ask you, do you control me, you should say no."
嗯，她只是说——她只是说，“当他们问你，你控制我吗，你应该说不。”
Wait. But isn't telling you to tell us that she isn't controlling rather controlling?
等一下。但告诉你要告诉我们她没有控制，这难道不是一种控制吗？
I think that that's the thing about my mom is she doesn't think she's hypocritical because it all comes from a place of just pure love. And she gave me little lines of explanations of what I should say and what stories I should tell. And I was just kind of like, "Yeah, those are good ideas." And she was like, "So are you going to do it?" And I was like, "You know, I might improvise." And she was like, "No improvisation, we need to plan." [LAUGHS]
我认为这就是关于我妈妈的事情，她不认为自己虚伪，因为这一切都源于纯粹的爱。她给了我一些我应该怎么说、应该讲什么故事的简短解释。我只是有点像，“嗯，那些是好点子。”她说，“那你打算做吗？”我说，“你知道，我可能会即兴发挥。”她说，“不许即兴发挥，我们需要计划。”（笑声）
Clearly, somebody is not sticking with the plan. But since she arrived at Stanford, Zoya has been pushing back on her mom more than she ever has. And the biggest thing they disagree about, the most serious battlefront in this war over how much control Zarna gets over Zoya's life, is what classes Zoya should take. When I asked Zoya, "Was your mom's voice in your head when you were picking your classes?" Her answer showed just how much her mom's voice is in her head.
显然，有人没有坚持计划。但自从她到达斯坦福后，卓娅反抗她妈妈的次数比以往任何时候都多。她们不同意的最大的事情，在这场关于扎娜对卓娅生活有多少控制权的战争中最严肃的前线，是卓娅应该选什么课。当我问卓娅，“当你选课时，你妈妈的声音在你的脑海里吗？”她的回答表明了她妈妈的声音在她脑海里有多少。
100%.
100%。
In fact, last year, when Zoya was a freshman, her mom did something very unusual for a Stanford parent. She sat in on Zoya's Zoom meetings with her academic advisor, mostly lurking off camera and making her wishes known to Zoya but sometimes speaking up. Zoya remembers one call, for instance, with an advisor.
事实上，去年，当卓娅是大一新生时，她妈妈做了一件对于斯坦福家长来说非常不寻常的事情。她坐在卓娅与导师的Zoom会议旁，大部分时间潜伏在镜头外，向卓娅表达她的愿望，但有时也会发言。卓娅记得一次会议，例如，与导师的对话。
I think the most embarrassing part of the call was my mom saying, "Zoya is only supposed to take computer science. She should only take computer science." And then, I think what was so embarrassing was she had said that right after I had gone on this whole tangent about how I loved learning about Latin and ancient cultures. And then she was like, but Zoya needs to take computer science, almost as if she hadn't heard what I had said. And the academic advisor was like-- her face just dropped. It was just so embarrassing.
我想通话中最尴尬的部分是我妈妈说，“卓娅只应该选计算机科学。她只应该选计算机科学。”然后，我想最尴尬的是，那是在我谈论我热爱拉丁语和古代文化之后她说的。然后她又说，但卓娅需要选计算机科学，几乎就像她根本没听到我说的话一样。而导师的脸——一下子沉了下来。真是太尴尬了。
I think she's thinking, oh, like, typical immigrant mom wants to control Indian daughter to do STEM, which I just hate because we're not even a stereotypically cultural family. It just was the worst feeling. I didn't want to be seen as weak. And I didn't want to be seen as something-- I had worked so hard to create this identity that wasn't just Indian girl does STEM. You know, that's so important to me. I want to be complex and interesting and seen as more than that. And I feel like I'm caught in this mismatch of cultures and mismatch of understanding of what education looks like.
我想她在想，噢，典型的移民母亲想要控制印度女儿去做理工科，我非常讨厌这一点，因为我们甚至不是一个刻板的文化家庭。那简直是最糟糕的感觉。我不想被看作软弱。我不想被看作某些……我努力创造了这样一个身份，不仅仅是做理工科的印度女孩。你知道，这对我来说太重要了。我想变得复杂而有趣，被看作不仅仅是那样。我觉得我被困在这种文化和对教育理解的不匹配中。
And to be clear, she doesn't think her mom is entirely wrong. When her mom says, "I'm paying for this. Why shouldn't I get to pick your courses?" Part of Zoya thinks, yeah, why should she be spending her mom's money to take an English class her mom doesn't like? Isn't that selfish of her?
明确一点，她并不认为她妈妈完全错了。当她妈妈说，“我在付钱。为什么我不能选你的课程？”卓娅的一部分想法是，是的，为什么她要花她妈妈的钱去上她妈妈不喜欢的英语课？她这样做不是自私吗？
But to show you just how messy and complicated all this is between them, I need to tell you this next story. Zoya knows her mom so well and is such a forceful, forward-looking kid, that Zoya is the reason that her mom, Zarna, became a stand-up comedian at all.
但为了向你展示她们之间这一切有多混乱和复杂，我需要告诉你接下来的故事。卓娅非常了解她妈妈，是一个非常有主见、有远见的孩子，卓娅就是她妈妈扎娜成为单口喜剧演员的原因。
Four years ago, when she was 16, Zoya saw how unhappy her mom was. She had trained to be a lawyer but didn't like it and stopped when she had her kids. She'd been home raising the kids for years. Here's Zarna.
四年前，当她16岁时，卓娅看到了她妈妈有多不快乐。她接受过律师培训，但不喜欢它，在有了孩子后就停止了。她在家里抚养孩子很多年了。这是扎娜。
I was dying, but I couldn't figure out what to do. I couldn't figure out what I should do. And she said to me, "Mom, all my friends love hanging out with you because they think you're funny. Why don't you do comedy?" And I was like, what is she talking about? Who's going to come and watch what I have to say? And what am I even going to say? I don't know what comedy people do. And she's like, "No, Mom, I really think you should do stand-up comedy." And I thought she had lost her mind.
我当时很痛苦，但不知道该怎么办。我不知道我应该做什么。她对我说，“妈，我所有的朋友都喜欢和你在一起，因为他们认为你很有趣。你为什么不做喜剧？”我当时想，她在说什么？谁会来看我想说的话？我到底要说什么？我不知道喜剧演员做什么。她说，“不，妈，我真的认为你应该做单口喜剧。”我想她一定是疯了。
She had so much fear going into stand-up comedy. I mean, it took me six months of being like, "Mom, you can do it. Mom, you can do it. You're so good at this." Like, all my friends would want to come to my house because she was just so funny and lively. She just had such a gift. Always her answer was like, "Oh, I'll just be a secretary or somewhere. Or I got a law degree. I could go exercise my law degree. I could go practice law." I was like, "Mom, you hated practicing law. You love telling stories."
她对单口喜剧怀有极大的恐惧。我是说，我花了六个月时间说，“妈，你能行的。妈，你能行的。你擅长这个。”就像，我所有的朋友都想来我家，因为她太风趣、太活跃了。她简直太有天赋了。她总是回答说，“哦，我会去做秘书或其他地方。或者我拿了法律学位。我可以运用我的法律学位。我可以去当律师。”我说，“妈，你讨厌当律师。你喜欢讲故事。”
So it took her all those months to convince her mom that she should do what she loved. And now it is not lost on Zoya that this is exactly what she's asking her mom to let her do at college.
所以她花了那几个月说服她妈妈做她喜欢的事。现在卓娅并没有忘记，这正是她要求她妈妈在大学里让她做的事情。
So I keep telling her that, where I'm like, "Mom, the reason you have your career is because I said, 'Do what you love'." And she was like, "Yeah, but you shouldn't do what you love. That's too scary." And I was like, "Mom!" [LAUGHS]
所以我一直告诉她，就像，“妈，你有今天的事业是因为我说，‘做你喜欢的事’。”她说，“是的，但你不应该做你喜欢的事。那太可怕了。”我说，“妈！”（笑声）
When I ask her mom about this, she says that it is different for her than for Zoya. When she started as a comedian, the family was financially secure. They were fine. Zoya doesn't have that, in her mom's view. She needs to invent a life for herself, where she's supporting herself. And some humanities degree-- a job as a writer, a job in the arts--
当我问她妈妈这件事时，她说对她来说和对卓娅来说是不同的。当她开始做喜剧时，家庭在经济上是安全的。他们过得很好。在她妈妈看来，卓娅没有那个条件。她需要为自己创造一种生活，自己供养自己。而某些人文学位——一份作家的工作，一份艺术领域的工作——
I mean, it's a very unstable, unknown path. You don't know what's next.
我是说，这是一条非常不稳定、未知的道路。你不知道接下来会发生什么。
It's just hard for her to put that feeling aside, given her past. What can I say? From my experience with my parents, who grew up without money and fought their way to professional jobs in the middle class, I'm really not sure there's anything that Zoya can say to Zarna, or Zarna to Zoya, to convince each other. It's almost like the parents did too good a job creating a safe life for Zoya. And now she's not scared the way they are about how badly things could go.
鉴于她的过去，她很难把那种感觉放在一边。我能说什么呢？根据我父母的经验，他们从小没钱，打拼出中产阶级的专业工作，我真的不确定卓娅能对扎娜说什么，或者扎娜能对卓娅说什么，来说服对方。这几乎就像父母在为卓娅创造安全生活方面做得太好了。而现在她不像他们那样害怕事情会变得多糟糕。
We live in fear. At least my husband and I-- she doesn't-- and for that, I'm grateful. She's very American in that way. She's a little bit fearless. She's like, whatever happens, we'll figure it out. But my husband and I are immigrants. We live in fear.
我们生活在恐惧中。至少我和我丈夫——她没有——对此，我很感激。她在那种方式上是非常美国的。她有点无畏。她就像，不管发生什么，我们会解决的。但我丈夫和我都是移民。我们生活在恐惧中。
And so Zarna doesn't trust Zoya to pick her own future.
所以扎娜不信任卓娅能选择自己的未来。
Because I don't see her as a person who's driven by the need to survive.
因为我不认为她是一个受到生存需求驱动的人。
I ran that by Zoya.
我把这一点告诉了卓娅。
Wow. I think-- I need to-- I don't know. I don't know how to even respond to that. That's insane. [LAUGHS] I've never heard it verbally explicitly said.
哇。我想——我需要——我不知道。我甚至不知道怎么回应那个。那太疯狂了。（笑声）我从来没听过有人明确地这么说出来。
Yeah, she thinks that her advice is better than what you think you want for yourself because she's more scared for you than you are. She's worried about you surviving.
是啊，她认为她的建议比你认为你对自己想要的更好，因为她对你比你对自己更害怕。她担心你的生存。
But I'm like, why do decisions have to be made out of fear? All of the people that I look up to as, like, role models all made their careers out of something they just love to do, even my mom. Why can't I be motivated by that instead of being motivated by fear constantly? I think she-- I wish she trusted herself as a parent a little bit too. Like, she really raised me right, and it's all there. Everything is sitting in my brain. So I just wish she knew that and could trust that a little bit.
但我说，为什么决定必须出于恐惧而做出？所有我视为榜样的那些人，他们的事业都是出于他们喜欢做的事，甚至我妈妈也是。为什么我不能以此为动力，而不是一直受恐惧的驱使？我想她——我希望她在作为父母方面也多信任自己一点。就像，她确实把我养得很好，都在那里了。一切都在我的大脑里。所以我只希望她知道这一点，并能对此多一点信任。
Zoya said that hearing that it took my mom till I was 41 years old to fully accept what I've done with my life made her heart hurt. She doesn't want to wait that long.
卓娅说，听到我妈妈直到我41岁才完全接受我对自己生活所做的事，她的心很痛。她不想等那么久。
Well, today's show was produced by Diane Wu. Elna Baker produced Act Two. Original music for Act One, Amy Bloom's story, by Found Objects and Jay Lifton. Music supervision by Karl Westman and Raife Burchell at Dirty Soup, and Stowe Nelson.
今天的节目由黛安·吴制作。埃尔娜·贝克制作了第二幕。第一幕，艾米·布鲁姆的故事的原创音乐由Found Objects和杰伊·利夫顿制作。音乐监督由脏汤（Dirty Soup）的卡尔·韦斯特曼和雷夫·伯切尔，以及斯托·尼尔森完成。
The people who put our show together today include Michael Comite, Andrea López Cruzado, Cassie Howley, Chana Joffe-Walt, Valerie Kipnis, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, Christopher Swetala, and Matt Tierney. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
今天参与制作我们节目的包括迈克尔·科米特、安德里亚·洛佩兹·克鲁扎多、卡西·豪利、查纳·乔菲-沃尔特、瓦莱丽·基普尼斯、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、纳迪亚·雷曼、瑞安·鲁梅里、阿丽莎·希普、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉和马特·蒂尔尼。我们的主编是萨拉·阿卜杜勒拉赫曼。我们的高级编辑是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑是埃马努埃莱·贝里。
It's our production fellow's last week with us. Michelle Navarro, this has been so lovely. You are such a good writer. We all hope to have you on the air here again. Special thanks today to Brett Wean, to Dr. Charles DeCarli, and Andrew Francis.
这是我们制作组研究员和我们在一起的最后一周了。米歇尔·纳瓦罗，这段时间太美好了。你是一个很好的作家。我们都希望你能再次回到我们的节目中。今天特别感谢布雷特·威恩、查尔斯·德卡利医生和安德鲁·弗朗西斯。
Our website-- ThisAmericanLife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 750 episodes for absolutely free. Also, there's tons of other stuff there too-- links to our television show-- you know, we have a television show-- videos, favorites lists-- again, ThisAmericanLife.org.
我们的网站是ThisAmericanLife.org，在那里你可以完全免费在线收听我们750多集的档案。此外，还有很多其他的东西——我们电视节目的链接——你知道，我们有一个电视节目——视频、收藏夹列表——再一次，ThisAmericanLife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he still remembers the day, back when he was a little boy years ago, when he wrote down the word "hug," and then he added the letter "E" to the end. He was stunned by his creation.
《美国生活》由公共广播交换平台PRX分发给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，他还记得那一天的情景，多年前他还是个小男孩的时候，他写下了“hug”（拥抱）这个词，然后在末尾加了一个“E”。他对自己创造的东西感到震惊。
Which was a huge-- I mean, that really took me aback. I was like, "Wow."
这对我来说是一个巨大的打击——我是说，那真的让我感到惊讶。我当时想，“哇。”
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回归。
[MUSIC - DENROY MORGAN, "I'LL DO ANYTHING FOR YOU"]
（音乐 - 丹洛伊·摩根，“为你我什么都愿做”）